that looks promising that looks very
promising
to be clear i'm scoping out the fps
numbers not the protagonist i mean i
play this game for the gameplay compared
to old-school lara croft this does look
a lot more promising
new year new gpu
according to the latest steam hardware
survey the most popular graphics card on
the platform is still the venerable if a
little aging gtx 1060 and that's what
we've got set up in our rig right here
and 90 of you are running at 1080p which
means that you're actually getting a
pretty decent experience out of that
card but
maybe you could use a higher frame rate
right you know treat yourself the
problem is that there hasn't been
anything worth upgrading to from this
thing because the rtx 2060 came in at a
much higher price that is to say
until today
meet
the radeon 5600
xt what could very well be the new
budget champ or will it
we'll find out after i tell you about
our sponsor freshbooks freshbookis is
the accounting software that's built for
how you want to work are you a small
business owner or a freelancer well go
get it
go get it the link's down below it's
always there it's always there
[Music]
the first thing i want to do is
acknowledge that this is going to be a
little bit different from our
traditional gpu reviews where we say
okay there's this one and there's all
these other ones and here's some bar
graphs and all that kind of good stuff
there will still be bar graphs and we do
still have this gpu and other ones but
because so many of you out there are
running this exact graphics card we
wanted to take more of a practical
real-world upgrade approach to it so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to take our gpu test bench which
is running a ryzen 3950x which has
pretty honestly pretty similar gaming
performance to any intel high-end cpu
from the last two or three years and
then we're going to start with our 1066
gig in here we're going to upgrade to
our 5600 xt and we're going to see how
it goes so anthony actually do you want
to jump in and get our suite rolling on
this thing one of the reasons that we
have a fully built up system for gpu
testing is that we don't want to give an
unfair advantage to open style coolers
like this one and this one and this one
compared to blower coolers we're making
these ones suck in their own
recirculated hot air just like they
would in your system at home are using
1080 max settings on everything yes okay
that makes perfect sense because much to
the disappointment of a lot of the
enthusiast community the 5600 xt
is not really targeting your 1440p gamer
and there's a couple of reasons for this
number one is that 1080p is still
by far the most popular gaming
resolution probably in no small part
thanks to the fact that high refresh
rate displays like the really high
refresh rate competitive ones are all
still 1080 and also because well if
we're being honest amd has had a heck of
a time building anything other than atp
gaming graphics card over the last few
years
with that said this is using the same
underlying tech as the 5700 xt so this
is a full fat navi 10 gpu the main
disadvantage here is what just clock
speed then uh clock speed power target
and it has a 192 192-bit memory bus and
six gigabytes of memory versus 256 and
eight gigabytes for the 5700 so that's
where you're saving some money and
that's where you're improving your
yields on the gpus but of course
compared to the 5700 which was really a
mid-range 1440p gaming card this is a
high-end 1080
low-end 1440. like if you're playing
last gen titles 1440p is going to be
fine but we're going to do all of our
testing at 1080 with a nice fast cpu to
see what kind of experience we can have
here i'm actually really excited to see
the numbers from this because honestly
one of the best indications of how good
an upcoming card is going to be
is what the competitors do to react to
it before you ever even get a chance to
benchmark the thing and nvidia already
sent out proactive
just so you know there's some great
pricing on what was it 1660 ti yeah i
think it was the ti because we're
probably gonna get rid of it soon yeah
but like
amd did that same thing i know with mega
56. nvidia's email was this one
board partner card an evga ko which
honestly the first time i remember them
using ko was back when nvidia was trying
to get rid of a whack ton of like
7 800 gpus or something like that the
first time i saw an evga ko and it was
basically the last hurrah for that gpu
and then it was gone so that
maybe gives us some idea of what the
exit strategy there is but it also gives
us some idea of how good we're expecting
this thing to be nvidia had to react so
that's a great sign because the reality
of it is the order of operations is the
first ones with access to the hardware
the manufacturers the next ones are
usually their competitors somehow they
always have this information and then it
comes to us so usually the the 4d chess
is already happening before we even get
to plug it into a system
uh one thing to note is that we're going
from a single 6-pin connector to a
single 8-pin connector so that might
tell us something about the power
consumption we can expect from the 5600
xt
i mean we already know something because
it is based on the same gpu as the
5700 series wait you guys were just
waiting for me you didn't run any
benchmarks well they're all done
oh oh right
okay right so that's the whole stick
here so anthony already ran the stock
numbers for the 5600 xt but amd
hinted that there might be quite a bit
of overclocking headroom in this card so
let's go ahead and see what we can do
what utility do you use for amd uh just
use radeon control slopes bring it on
subscribe right okay this is their new
software performance there we go tuning
advanced control yeah that gives you
control over the frequency and voltage
curve cool
okay so where do we want it then so we
just want to expand it out as far as
it'll go i guess
um
maybe yeah
so they've got a much better looking
interface than nvidia but it's
effectively the same thing you got you
got one you got one button you press the
button well yeah there's also the um
power tuning which is the more
impressive of the two well not not
really impressive but useful all right
sure that looks pretty good whatever
okay so where's the power control here
we go power tuning power limit okay yeah
so this is basically nvidia overclocking
yep and we also can do the vram as well
max frequency okay and
about 110 megahertz sure why not okay
cool
so let's apply that and see what happens
we can also uh if you go to the fan as
well uh right now i think the max is 39
okay let's give it 80. it's not going to
instantly set it to 80. it's just the
maximum that it'll request
play let's see if it just immediately
crashes and that was a very haphazard
overclock
it's about as much as i did when i was
preparing for this so we'll see how this
works of course you don't know what the
stock numbers look like oh yeah no i
don't okay so i just get to be
that much more impressed
wow
what's the pricing of this card it's
this particular card is 289 289
that is a big upgrade so all of a sudden
you're going from
60 fps
to yeah you can comfortably justify the
investment in a 120 hertz display
and you're really going to be getting
the most out of it especially with how
affordable it is to get a free sync
capable display these days yeah and the
fact that most of them that say g-sync
now are also freesync of course it's
easy to look good against your
competitor's last gen product so
let's go ahead and level the playing
field by bringing in the gtx 1660 super
and the
ti now this one is priced a little bit
lower but comes in a little bit lower
also performance wise whereas the 1660
ti is clearly the head-to-head
competitor here this one is priced
exactly the same has a little bit less
raw performance but if you care about
some of nvidia's well nvidia specific
features not rtx mind you this is a gtx
but things like nvidia's touring and
vent encoder which does offer better
quality even if amd does have some sort
of counter punches like the fact that
theirs supports 16 streams yeah it's
it's a little bit strange considering
they're otherwise very focused on gamers
and gaming performance
which i mean to me a higher quality
encoder would make more sense than
faster encoder but
okay oh hold on guys literally the day
after we shot this video nvidia dropped
the rtx 2060's price to 299 completely
invalidating our comparison against the
gtx 1660 ti
that's a good thing for you guys but it
did mean
more work for us here's how the rtx 2060
looks next to the rx 5600 xt
as you can see amd is still in the lead
here but nvidia's now within striking
distance with a price difference of just
20 dollars amd is slightly undercutting
nvidia with better performance but
if you're like me you might consider
paying the extra twenty dollars and
overclocking the rtx yourself to get
that rtx support and the new end bank
encoder regardless that's great news for
everyone because not only is there a new
card on the block but at least it's
competitive in this price range bringing
other more expensive hardware down in
price so yeah that's great just too bad
it couldn't have got here sooner
see ya
that's just me not everyone cares about
the encoder that's built into their gpu
anyway though not everybody streams on
twitch tv for example so when it comes
time to choose your next upgrade the
only thing we really know for sure here
is that you probably shouldn't pick up a
gtx 1060 at 289 dollars but either team
red or team green has a legitimate
offering especially once you factor in
the generous head room for overclocking
on the 5600 xt another interesting point
is that we don't actually know that
that's the limit for these things that
was the end of the slider and anthony
was trying to use a soft power play
table in order to increase it but that
seems to be locked down now amd has
hinted that they might unlock more
capabilities in the future yeah they
didn't say anything substantial about it
they just said that well we'll look at
it when we know more about the
reliability figures we just don't want
boards to go up and smoke
so that makes sense it does make sense
speaking of going up in smoke
my
attempts to pretend that i care about
the quality of my segways this video is
brought to you by privacy.com anytime we
buy something online we give access to
our personal information to merchants
and their data partners and this happens
without our clear consent well with
privacy.com you're equipped to keep your
financial life more secure online
privacy generates virtual card numbers
so you never give your actual credit
card number to the merchants that you
buy from online and you can create up to
12 cards a month on their free personal
plan they've also got two new tiers pro
and teams pro is ten dollars a month and
gives you access to everything in the
free plan plus one percent cash back on
all purchases up to 36 cards a month and
more security and privacy features and
the team's plan is more for small
business owners it's 25 bucks a month
you get everything in the pro plan plus
a dedicated account manager 60 cards a
month and transaction limits that are
tailored to your business needs they're
pci dss compliant they use military
grade encryption and they offer
two-factor authentication and since they
make their money for merchants the free
tier has no cost to you whatsoever and
if you sign up today you'll even get
five dollars for nothing so go to
privacy.com forward slash linus that's
privacy.com forward slash linus and
check it out today thanks for watching
guys if you're looking for another video
to check out have we done any cool gpu
stuff recently uh trying to think okay
forget it check out our recent budget
cpu roundup 50 cpu showdown wait is that
going to be out before this video goes
up maybe not get subscribed so you don't
miss that